[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like to answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor genre
vice-president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact on Thanksgiving Day 1936 -
Minnesota boys named Harold and Charlie
Peterson decided to go hunting with a
man who worked on the family farm the
two brothers in their companion wood
good hunters but accidents can happen to
the best of marksman and that day a
bullet from a hired man's gun
accidentally struck young Harold in the
face when the wounded youngster reached
the hospital it was found that the
bullet had lodged at the base of his
skull so near the spinal cord that the
doctors did not dare operate to remove
it the 15 year old boy was told that he
would have to take his chances and live
with the bullet lodged at the base of
his skull for the rest of his life
fortunately it gave him no real trouble
anytime he almost forgot about it then
in 1960 Harold now 39 years old and
running the same family farm felt that
he might be coming down with a sore
throat a few days later he had a violent
coughing spasm he coughed and often
finally he coughed up a bullet the same
soft-nosed rifle bullet that had lodged
in his neck 24 years before friends did
you know that the Bible speaks of things
often forgotten coming back or stay
tuned for more as amazing facts brings
you this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred seven eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven now
let's join our host pastors Jean Ross
hello friends welcome to Bible answers
live this is a live international
interactive Bible study and if you have
a Bible related question you've come to
the right place
our phone lines are now open and just
give us a call and you can ask your
Bible question on the air we don't claim
to have all the answers but we do have
some very powerful software in front of
us on our computers that we can look up
different Bible verses and we would just
love to chat with you about the Bible
one of the best uses of time is to study
the scriptures and that's what this is
all about if you have a Bible related
question the phone line to call here to
the studio is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven that number
again is eight hundred four sixty three
seven two nine seven I'm going to give
you that number here in just a moment
I'll let you get something ready to
write on if it's easier to remember the
acronym is 800 God says and that number
ready here it is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven a pastor Doug is
away today but working the phones for us
here in the studio is pastor Marshall
McKinsey publishing director at amazing
facts Marshall welcome thanks for
helping out with the program thanks for
the invitation why don't you start the
program with the word of Prayer sounds
good father in heaven we thank you so
much for this opportunity we have to
just open your word and to discuss and
to study together we pray for the Holy
Spirit we pray for the wisdom that he
brings that we may have right
understandings we thank you so much to
gain courage and strength for the times
in which we live in Jesus name we pray
amen amen
well you know Marshall we open the
program by talking about a story of a
young man well he was young at the time
a Harold Peterson who coughed up a
bullet now he was living back 19
thirty-six is when this accident
occurred and then some what was it
twenty four years later the coughed and
up came this bullet a long time to
collage in the back of your neck it is a
long time and you know when I heard you
read the story and share that fact it
almost sounds too hard to believe mm-hmm
to have a bullet in your neck for 24
years and and then all of a sudden just
you cough it up
yes that's right somehow the body was
able to move the bullet to the point
where actually it came out in the throat
and II was able to eventually cuff it up
you know and and the point you made
relating to a judgment sometimes we
think because if I will really talk
about a judgment Dada
it just sounds too far-fetched mm-hmm
and and yet it really does it sure does
in Matthew chapter 12 verse 36 Jesus had
this to say he said but I say unto you
that every idle word that men shall
speak they shall give an account of
thereof in the day of judgment for by
thy words you shall be justified and by
your words you shall be condemned I'm
also reminded of the Old Testament verse
meekly ciasses chapter 12 verse 14 it
says God shall bring every work into
judgment with every secret thing whether
it be good or whether it be evil in
other words every detail of our life
will one day be included in that
judgment this happens at they're great
judgment experience that the Bible
speaks of it's taking place at the very
end now it's true that we are saved by
grace but the Bible teaches us that we
are judged by our works and somebody
might wonder well how can that be if
you're saved by grace and yet judge by
works well the truth is your works is a
demonstration of your faith and without
faith no one can please God so yes there
is a judgment and all of our works our
words our thoughts are going to be borne
into judgment now for the Christian we
don't have to fear the judgment in talk
about judgment and is often thoughts of
fear and what we all know we have sinned
the Bible says all have sinned and
fallen short of the glory of God but for
the Christian there is hope in the
judgment because we have an advocate
with the father and that's Jesus we have
somebody who died so that we can be
forgiven and that we can face the
judgment without fear right we have the
priest of
priests working on our behalf absolutely
we've got an attorney who has never lost
the case and if I put our confidence in
Jesus and trust in him and coming to a
saving relationship with him
we need not fear that judgment well the
Bible doesn't quite us but to say about
this judgment and more importantly how
we can be found in Christ when their
judgment comes we have a study guide and
it's entitled case closed and it talks
about this judgment tell us a little bit
about it
you know it just goes through the
specifics in relationship to the
judgment it encourages it challenges us
it helps us to understand God's big plan
right and how he's working it to a
completion to benefit all those who love
him absolutely there is good news in the
judgment that's right exactly and they
can you know pastor John they can get it
by just calling 1-800 813 four seven you
just call that resource line and you can
ask for this free offer yes just ask for
the study guide called case closed and
the number one more time is 800 eight
three five six seven four seven are we
going to give you several numbers that
is the resource phone line if you would
like to receive any of the free material
that we talked about on the program just
call us on that phone line if you have a
Bible question to speak to us here in
the studio the number is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven and
leave God it's looking pretty good I
think we have two lines open so good
time to give us a call that's 800 four
six three seven two nine seven if you
don't get through immediately I just
stay on the phone we'll get your call as
soon as we can turn well we're ready to
go to the phone lines who do we have
first our first caller is Peyton from
Shelby Tennessee's Peyton you're on the
air Bible answer is live and pastor John
hello hi welcome to the program oh my
god equestions
about the keys of heaven mentioned in
Matthew 16:19 yes Matthew chapter 16
verse 19 let me read it for everyone
Jesus says and I say unto you that you
are Peter this is Christ talking to the
Apostles in a particular to Peter and on
this rock I will build my church and the
gates of Hades or hell shall not prevail
against it
and then verse 19 and here's the verse
you're talking about and I will give you
the keys of the kingdom of heaven and
whatever you bind on earth will be bound
in heaven and whatever you loose on
earth will be loosed in heaven now
sometimes people have wondered well what
is this key to the kingdom that Jesus
gave his disciples and Peter in
particular did he somehow give them the
ability to determine who's going to go
to heaven or who is not gonna go to
heaven and is that what you're wondering
Peyton
I just wanted men by what is binding
with loosening like these what was it me
mother okay to bind what to loosen the
context of the whole passage here is
Jesus is telling his disciples that he
is going to give them something that
will open up heaven to those who receive
it and believe it and will close heaven
to those who reject it now what was it
that Jesus was given to the disciples
that they would take to the world that
would open heaven to those who receive
it well he gave them the gospel
the disciples were given the Great
Commission you read about that in
Matthew 28 where jesus said go preach
the gospel in every nation kindred
tongue take it to all the world those
who believe and are baptized they'll be
saved those who don't believe in essence
are closing heaven upon themselves so
it's not an arbitrary choice that the
disciples making saying well this person
I like him so yes I'm going to let him
be saved in this person I don't like so
I'm not going to let them be saved
because our salvation is not based upon
an individual a human being it's based
upon our faith in Jesus he is the Savior
so when it talks about binding and
loosening it's just talking about the
gospel that Jesus gave the disciples
which brings life or heaven to those who
receive it and brings death eternal
death to those who reject it and they're
always doing the work of Christ mm-hmm
they're not doing an independent of
Christ because he says I have the keys
but in relation yes oh that's right so
they are working with Christ in taking
the gospel to the world but each person
based on whether they respond to that
gospel how they respond to the gospel
determines where they heaven is open to
them or heaven is closed to them
does that help people mm-hmm sure does
all right very good
well thanks your call I appreciate it no
I'm thinking there we have a book called
can a save man choose to be lost
which I think Payton would find
interesting to receive that Payton just
call us on our resource phone number and
as for the book can I save man choose to
be lost and that number Payton is one
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven one eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven you'll really
enjoy that read and as much as we're
pavements for any anybody listening and
by the way if you like me and when you
think of something you want to do it
immediately I think of a good book I
want to read it right away I don't want
to wait for the coming the mail well you
can go to the website amazing facto RG
and you can read it this evening just
type in the search bar can a save man
choose to be lost it's not a long book
but it's got a great many resources and
scripture it's a good study who do we
have next next we have Denise from
Huntsville Alabama Denise you're on the
earth Bible answers live yes thanks god
bless you guys thanks for calling work
did she do I wanted to find it I wanted
to know about the Jews and they know
when or if they stopped doing animal
sacrifices and if they because I don't
I've never heard they still do the
animal sacrifices so how do they account
for this and if they do not do animal
sacrifices anymore alright well that's a
good question they don't believe in
Jesus right
they don't accept Jesus of Messiah they
are some who recognize him as you know a
good man a moral man but they refuse to
acknowledge him as the Messiah as the
Christ well after the death of Jesus
those who receive Jesus disciples and
the Christians they no longer are
involved in animal sacrifices they
recognize Jesus to be the Lamb of God
that takes away the sins of the world
but animal sacrifices continued in
Jerusalem up until 70 AD in 70 AD
Jerusalem and the temple was
destroyed by the Romans the Jews were
scattered throughout the Roman Empire
and they weren't able to perform the
various sacrificial services that will
perform the Jerusalem at the temple and
so as time went on a number of the
Jewish rabbis sort of spiritualize the
sacrifices because it became
inconvenient became something that was
frowned on in the societies where they
were scattered
so to spiritualize then even today Jews
don't even Orthodox Jews don't sacrifice
animals but their spiritual eyes that
whole concept of the sacrifice so okay
that's that's not yes I can I can
understand that so how do they spiritual
eyes or tongue for their sin as of in
this modern day how do they how are they
able to do that are they able to atone
for the sins if they don't sacrifice and
they don't believe in Jesus well I think
they do acknowledge that you need to
recognize you know your sins and you do
need to recognize that just lets them
brings death that is an Old Testament
principle that a number of those more
Orthodox Jews recognize but there is a
certain degree of works associated with
their religion and if you're good and
you do good works that to some degree
will help atone for your misdeeds or
your sins so without Jesus and without
grace and without the forgiveness that
comes by faith in Christ all you're
ready left with is a works based type of
religion and that's kind of what it has
developed into without the sacrificing
and that's our person atones for their
sins by but being a good person and
doing good deeds okay well thank you
thank you that that kind of comes with
me for a few days I started thinking
about and I appreciate the answer it has
it satisfies all right well very good
thank you for calling greens if you have
a Bible question frames our phone line
is open
the number is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven that's 804 63 72 and 97
and who do we have max Marshall um
Pastor John
we've got Timothy from Spring Creek
Nevada Timothy you're on the air with
Pastor Jonah Bible answers live air
their pastor Jean and I didn't catch the
name of your friend you have today
yeah it's past the Marshall McKenzie you
can call him Marshall past Marshall yep
- Marshall hi Timothy
okay so my question tonight was about
forgot where it was but the Bible is
talking about males men in the church
being able to be pastors or preachers
because of having multiple eyes I'm not
sure if they're talking about at once or
throughout the life I've been there wife
passed away or divorce through immoral
acts of you know adult adultery and so
etc chatter and I camera what it was
where was but I'm not sure if I was
talking about at one time as in multiple
obsessed with adultery or fits
throughout their lives
okay good coercion Iran yeah yeah we've
happy to the verse I think you're
referring to is first Timothy chapter 3
verse 2 and then you find the same
principle in 1st Timothy chapter 3 verse
12 this is the Apostle Paul giving
instruction to the church and the Oh
deigning of different positions like
elda and deacon and there it says I'm
just looking in 1st Timothy chapter 3
verse 2 a bishop or an elder must be
blameless the husband of one wife
temperate sober-minded good behavior and
so on and so forth so one of the
characteristics is given is that he
needs to be a husband of one wife now
it's not talking about a widow or a
widower I should say who is remarried
his wife dies and then he remarries
after that it's not talking about that
it's talking about having multiple wives
at the same time now of course we find
polygamy was prevalent in the Old
Testament not only amongst some of the
pagan religions but even amongst the
Hebrews there were times where someone
would have multiple wives you think of
Hannah's husband there were two wives
involved Solomon had a whole slew and
David had more than one wife and there
were many others um it was never God's
perfect ideal one day the Pharisee
came to Jesus and they spoke about a
woman that had a husband and then he
died and so she married the brother and
he died and so on and pushy ended up
marrying seven and then in the
resurrection they said well who is she
going to be married to and Jesus then
explained that biblical marriage is
between a man and a woman and ideally it
you know it's for life but if somebody
dies or in the case of adultery that
person is then free to go get married
again so it's not saying that if you've
been married more than once that you
cannot be an elder in the church but you
can't have more than one wife at the
same time and polygamy was also
practiced in the Roman Empire not to the
extent of some of the other pagan areas
but there were clusters where that was
permitted and even they were converts
from paganism into Christianity who
might have more than one life you know
it's interesting I spent some time
overseas in Africa and we were in will
missionaries in different parts and one
area in particular I remember one of the
challenges in the church was people who
wanted to become Christians who had
multiple wives we spent some time in us
in a country called Swaziland and it so
happened that the king of the country
had multiple wives and a number of his
wives were actually Christians and they
attended the church and we were at and
he was very friendly towards Christians
they didn't quite know what to do though
with all of his wives too you know how
do we deal with that so yeah there are
still places in the world where this is
a concern in order to hold a position of
an alder yet you have to be married to
one wife okay and did that include some
divorce through adultery yes if somebody
breaks the marriage covenant through
adultery and there is a divorce that
person then is free to remarry yeah okay
that's that's the principle given by
Christ it's not it's not wanted that's
only allowance in a battle for divorce
yes that's not yeah that's the one
that's the only allowance given now of
course if somebody is in a relationship
with their life is threatened they need
to remove themselves from that
relationship but
you know these great ways one can do
that through separation legal separation
but officially divorced adulteries is
the reason given in Scripture okay you
know we do have a board but they might
find interesting on the subject it's
called marriage a-holes and remarriage
it kind of gets into this a little bit
it's a book written by pastor Doug it's
a good read
and I think it'll answer a lot of these
questions so just call our resource
phone number and you can ask for the
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage and Timothy that number is
1-800-308-3515 four seven and that's
where you can just ask and they'll send
you the book the book married a medieval
era scroll summary marriage all right
who do we have next
we have Mel in New Jersey City New
Jersey
Mel you're on the air with Bible answers
live Pastor John hi Mel welcome to the
program good evening good evening god
bless you moving in Revelation is also
about changing anything in the Bible
right yes
now all these different translations of
the Bible a friend of mine Allah Jehovah
Witness and he had a problem of the
department so I let him stay with me for
a little while and he brought his Bible
from the yoga with the sub I'm a Baptist
and I need my Bible to is already at
dawn he passed away but he left his
Bible there so I'm considering buying
another Bible so I grabbed his Bible
opened it up and I've been reading it in
in my studies now my question is he
translations are they a changing words
they claim they want to make it more
understood by the reader different
translations but is that changing the
Bible or changing the words well let me
yeah let me give you a couple of
principles that you want to bear in mind
um first of all there are two types of
Bibles English Bibles that you can find
there is a translation and there is a
paraphrase I want to explain the
difference the translation is where a
translator went to the original
languages of course the
I was written in Hebrew and in Greek and
a little bit of Aramaic in the Book of
Daniel but a translation takes those
original languages and translates it
into English that's called a translation
but in addition to that there are a
number of paraphrased Bible versions out
there and paraphrase is a pastor or a
scholar might take an English Bible and
then they rewrite that using different
words to try and clarify the meaning of
the Bible and that's called a paraphrase
and some very popular paraphrase today
is the Living Bible and very popular but
it's not a it's not a pure translation
so one needs to be careful when reading
a paraphrased version is probably okay
to kind of get some thoughts on the text
but when it comes to deep doctrinal
study I always encourage people to find
a solid Bible translation and when it
comes to translation there are two
families of manuscripts that are
typically used there is the Byzantine
family of many manuscripts and then
there's the Alexandrian set of
manuscripts they've very similar but
there's some slight differences maybe in
certain words used or maybe portions are
missing in the one set of translation
than the other personally I like the
Byzantine family of scripts you have
translations like the King James Version
the New King James the Revised Standard
Version these are really solid
translations in virtually in the
American standards a very good version
of some of the newer translations like
the NIV they lean more to the next lay
Island or the Alexandrian family of text
and as I said they're very very similar
but personally I prefer more the
Byzantine family which is the King James
New King James and alike so that's
something to bear in mind now as far as
I understand the jobber witness is more
of a paraphrase than a clean translation
from the original text because you'll
find a number of very significant
differences in the J / witness Bible as
you would in the King James of the New
King James so my question is again is
judge changing the Bible
when the manure went in in Revelation it
said do not change any of this stuff in
the Bible will be a curse and all the
Bible to whoever changed yeah no
absolutely I you know if you're trying
to tamper with the Word of Life be
careful and I think that's the warning
that revelation gives it's not for us to
try and change the scripture to make it
culturally acceptable I know there's
some strong truth that's found in the
scripture in some of these modern
translations or paraphrases they try and
water down these strong messages to be
more culturally acceptable and then
revelation says don't do that the
dangerous thing yeah a trend like Pastor
John is saying now a translation doesn't
mean they're messing with Scripture if
it's a literal translation I'm taking it
from the literal language and I'm just
translating it into our language when I
start messing with the thoughts yes that
are conveyed from those languages that's
when I start to add to or take away from
and and you can run into a danger in
some paraphrases when they kind of do
that so paraphrases are more like a
devotional reading you got to kind of be
careful but if you're really wanting to
study a literal translation from the
original like pastor john is saying is a
great way to go and and it's not
tampering with the original language you
know something that I'd encourage I do
this all the time in my study I have in
it available now they are free software
programs that you can download on your
computer the one that I like to use from
time to time is called a sword and it
actually gives you the English
translation of the verse and then you
could look at the Hebrew now you might
not even be able to read Hebrew or Greek
but you can click on the words and I'll
tell you what the actual meaning of that
original word is and you can see how
they translated it you can compare
different translations of the Bible you
can look at paraphrases and it helps us
to study the original understanding of
the text so yes when it comes to Bible
study find a good translation and we
need to be careful of those translations
that add to or take away from the
Scriptures that's a very dangerous thing
well you've been most helpful god bless
you and keep you thank you for calling
now we appreciate it you know we just I
just thought
Marshall we do have a
book the ultimate resource fast the one
that came to my mind a book written by
pastor Doug talking about the Bible
talking about where the Bible came from
the different translations how to study
the Bible I think it's just a great read
for anyone it Mel it's entitled the
ultimate resource and you can all get it
if you dial 1 885 6 7 4 7 anybody
listening one eight hundred eighty three
five six seven four seven and you can
just ask for the ultimate resource
that's the name of the book called the
ultimate resource we'll be able to send
it to anybody who calls and asks and you
know why you on the phone talking or
asking for that free offer you can also
ask to sign up for the free amazing
facts Bible correspondence school we
have 27 lessons that cover all of the
important biblical truths both in the
old and new Testament and we'll send it
to you for free in the mail you'll
actually read the lesson and filling a
little questionnaire at the end you mail
that back two amazing facts we will
grade your response and we'll send you
out the next batch of lessons and all of
this is free just go and ask for it when
you call 883 five six seven four seven
so I'm interested in the amazing facts
Bible correspondence course and we'll be
more than happy to send that to you in
the mail well friends you hear the music
playing in the background we are not
going to go away we're just going to
take a short break and kind of catch our
breath and we're going to have station
identification for those listening
around the country
and we'll be back with more Bible
questions don't go away
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to light the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore com in six days God created
the heavens and the earth for thousands
of years man has worshipped God on the
seventh day of the week now each week
millions of people worship on the first
day what happened why did God create a
day of rest does it really matter what
day we worship who is behind this great
shift discover the truth behind God's
law and how it was changed visit Sabbath
truth com can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vo RG @ AF p vo RG
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
materials all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vo RG every bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
seven four seven once again that's 808
three five six seven four seven now
let's join pastor Jean Ross for more
Bible answers live
[Music]
hello friends this passage on Ross
pastor Doug is out this evening but this
is a live interactive International
Bible study and we love studying the
Scriptures together if you have a Bible
question we would love to hear from you
this evening our phone line here to the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven and if
you just joined us this is a perfect
time to call and ask your Bible question
we'll try and answer as many of them as
we can
looks like we've got two lines still
open so a good time to get in there and
give us a call and I think we have
somebody lined up to ask a question who
do we have next we do Charles from
Huntsville Alabama Charles Iran Bible
answers live master John yes sir how you
doing tonight fellas doing very well
thanks you're cool Charles okay well
here's my question it's kind of a
two-part question sure um it's about the
Saints that were resurrected at the time
of Jesus either crucifixion or
resurrection the first part of the
question is where they resurrected when
he was crucified were they resurrected
when he was resurrected because the
wording is a little weird there and the
second part of my question is I've heard
pastor Doug Batchelor mentioned that
they went to heaven after they were
resurrected but I can't find any
scriptural support for that sure yeah
absolutely we do it yeah let's take
let's take it down two parts the first
is what is the verse with reference to
those being resurrect at the time of
Christ's resurrection well use the verse
Matthew 27 verse 53 I'm going to read
this to you oh well you know what let me
just get the context actually starting
verse 51 Matthew 26 27 51 it says then
behold the veil in the temple was torn
in two from top to bottom in the earth
quaked and the rocks were split and the
graves were opened and many of the
bodies of the Saints which had fallen
asleep were raised and coming out of the
graves after his resurrection
they appeared into the holy city and
appeared to many so the first question
is well when were these people
resurrected well we know that the great
earthquake that
broke open they graze occurred when the
veil was torn in the temple that
happened at the point of Christ's
crucifixion it's quite possible that
they rose at that point but they didn't
appear in the city that being the New
Jerusalem or the Jerusalem I should say
the the old city until after Christ was
resurrected that's kind of the context
that we're looking at you in this verse
so it wasn't until Sunday that they
appeared in Jerusalem and then
relational hung out at the graveyard I
don't know the day or two it doesn't say
okay it doesn't say it's pretty clear
yet though in verse 53 it says and
coming out of the graves then you know
the original language doesn't have
commas that's added by the translators
so it's a coming out of the graves comma
after his resurrection they went into
the holy city and appeared to many so
that it is as though they didn't appear
in the new Jew in the Jerusalem in the
city until after Christ rose from the
dead yeah pastor Marshalls this kind of
goes back to an Old Testament feast with
the wave sheaf and this was kind of like
the the first I guess you could say
harvest of Christ's ministry right and
his death and so he was actually
fulfilling the wave sheaf this was kind
of his first and they were there to
testify that then he rose from the dead
yeah and he's a lot that he died because
everybody saw that but rather that he
rose that was a powerful testimony that
they gave that the intense approach from
day because remember every because the
priest wanted to keep it quiet right if
it really did happen that's why we set
guards we're not going to say anything
open that while you're sleeping they
stole the body of Jesus oh yeah these
people that no one had seen before
suddenly appeared in the city and said
oh no he rose from the dead that's why
I'm here so that was a powerful
testimony but what happened to them
that's the second part of your question
well the Bible tells us you finally feed
in chapter 4 verse 7 there is a
reference to Christ the sanction I'll
read it it's Ephesians chapter 4
actually was a tease the one therefore
he says when he ascended on high talking
about Jesus ascending to heaven he led
captivity captive and gave gifts to men
now we know that those who are in the
grave the Bible sometimes
to them has been held captive in the
grave but here is a group that rose from
the grave they were once held captive
but they were freed they rose from the
dead and when Jesus ascended on high
when he ascended to heaven though he led
those who are captive by the grave he
led them to heaven and he gave gifts to
men so many Bible scholars believe that
those who appeared in Jerusalem after
the resurrection we don't know how long
they were there but they ascended up to
heaven with Jesus because Christ had
gone to heaven several times was forty
days after the reservation when he
finally went up but it's quite possible
that they were there for a period of
time and then ascended up with Jesus hmm
okay Ephesians well is that again an
occasion yeah he's in chapter 4 and
verse 8 okay thank you very much for
your time yeah thanks for Col Charles
good question I know a lot of folks
wonder about this group and you know
there's no other reference of them in
the early church you don't read about
this group of people who are resurrected
in Acts you'd think that if there was a
big group raised and they stayed on the
earth that they would have played some
part in the church at least been
mentioned and then of course they were
raised from the dead
they were probably raised to testify and
not to die again so they were taking to
heaven like we're saying earlier it's
interesting you back to the there was an
offering before the harvest like the
true full yes harvest was given if you
go back the Old Testament but like the
first there's like a firstfruits yeah
that we're actually given and and these
were like the firstfruits of Christ's
earthly ministry as he's presenting
himself before the Father right here's
the fruit of my sacrifice and the first
timers are given the rest will come
later on that's right given enough time
of course the great resurrection takes
place at the second coming of Christ so
good question there all right if you
have a Bible question of phone line he's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's 800 four 63 72 97 who
do we have name Pastor John we have Jack
from Clarksville Indiana Jack you're on
the air with Bible answers live yes
thank you for taking my call and god
bless you all
well thanks for calling Jack how can we
help well
to make a real short comment I get my
phone bill every month another I got a
verizon phone and all that bill I got
you know the number to call how many
minutes a talk and a wife said who are
you talking to for 45 minutes in an hour
I could I couldn't think
oh what a wallet this one just now
dawned on me I've set here on old that's
what it is so I'll be able to explain
that to her won't tell your wife you're
using the time very wisely you were
talking about the scriptures so that's a
good that's a good thing I'm Jack Jack
I'm an over other truck driver and of
course ice trucker I got a reputation
you know jack
again go ahead like what's your question
okay
I was listened to another teacher or a
Bible commentator and he was saying that
we don't have Jesus has already died on
a cross we don't have to ask for
forgiveness anymore that we could repent
and change our ways but Jesus is already
forgiven us but we don't have to ask him
to go back and forgive us again I was
just a little bit confused on that you
know I mean to that
yeah I've heard that before and I'm
always wondering why would a preacher
say that especially in the light of what
the Bible says I'm just going to give
you one verse Darrell Meany
but here's one breath first John Matthew
- characterization one I'm blanking are
there you go - but you know this one in
first John chapter 1 verse 9 says if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness not up now how
somebody can get around that it's pretty
clear if we confess our sins there is a
condition if we say yep Jesus died for
our sins but we're unwilling to confess
our sins to him and acknowledge our sins
and ask for forgiveness how can he
forgive us he's not going to force
forgiveness upon a person only those who
recognize they need of forgiveness and
ask and confess well then God is able to
forgive so yeah it's kind of a strange
teaching I've heard it out
there and it seems like it's become
popular by some rather prominent
preachers but it's just not biblical and
sort of a dangerous teaching I thought
that and I just was really confused
about it thank you very much
well thanks for cold yes good points and
important subject you know and I thought
pastor Jonathan ever liveth to make
intercession for us yes he's he knows he
needs to intercede there's there's times
that's right that may happen in our
lives but he thirteen early fakes and we
stumble in full and we got to go to
Christ and sincerity to forgive us okay
that's the condition that's required in
order to be forgiven if you have a Bible
question the phone line is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
that'll bring you here to the studio
with your Bible question this evening
and we still got about twenty minutes or
so with your Bible questions so give us
a call who's our next follow our next
caller is Carl from Maryland Carl you're
on the air with Bible answers line and
Pastor John hi Carl welcome to the
program good thank you I appreciate that
and your question this evening I guess
it would be in two parts that thought of
it I'm infused personally I'm confused
by the Trinity okay I understand that
the Holy Spirit is God Christ is God and
so is the father a God the Father I
don't quite understand how they
interrelate it confuses me okay what
what expounded or increase my confusion
was a red ant a bleeder than that that
the Apostles worshiped across so then
that caused me great confusion because
when I prayed to God the Father as
Christ said we should do in the gospel
we also pray to Christ
okay does that make sense yeah you know
I'm a little confused and I don't want
to pay to Christ because in the Gospels
price for specific roommate to God the
Father he gave us the Lord's Prayer as a
guideline it's not that I'm not me not
that I want to reject Christ obviously
that's not the case
I'm just confused okay good question
well let's let's take the first part
about the Godhead or the Trinity it is a
deep study I'm going to be talking to
God aim that there's only so much that
we can understand about God and God has
revealed certain things to us about who
he is in the scriptures but there are
also some strange ideas related to the
Trinity or they or the Godhead arm first
of all the Bible is very clear that the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit are
three separate beings there are three
separate personalities and in scripture
you read about Jesus here on the earth
and his baptism the Holy Spirit coming
upon him in the form of a dove and a
voice from heaven the voice of the
Father saying this is my beloved Son in
whom I'm well pleased they interact with
each other
Jesus prayed to the Father the Holy
Spirit responded to Christ when Jesus
would perform a miracle the Holy Spirit
would do certain things so the three
members of the Godhead interact amongst
themselves now when we talk about God
being one what we need to recognize is
that they all share the characteristics
of deity there are three separate beings
but the Father creates his life in an in
and of himself no beginning is eternal
he is all-powerful he knows everything
those same characteristics are shared by
Christ and by the Holy Spirit so they
share the same characteristics but they
are three separate beings so that's the
first part incidentally just one of the
quick thought in the Old Testament
speaking of God it says here he Israel
the Lord thy God is one and it's
interesting the word one there in the
Hebrew is in the plural form in the
Hebrew there is a singular form for one
and a plural form for one you probably
heard the verse in Genesis where God
says for this reason shall a man leave
his father and his mother and be joined
to his wife and the two shall become one
that is the plural form of the word one
meaning one in purpose one in design one
in focus so God is one in purpose and
his plan to save mankind
that doesn't mean that there's only one
being that's revealed in different ways
it gets all confusing so anyway that's
that's what we have with reference to
the Godhead or the Trinity the second
question that you had was remind me what
the second part was
the second part was I read an ad well
personally in the Gospels Christ gave us
the Lord's Prayer oh that's right lady
Bob yes could be tracked and and in Acts
the Apostles from what I read worshiped
Christ
okay so I'm a little confused here
because I get that they're separate
entity I got that impression from when I
rented the Tower of Babel
yeah we were split apart two different
languages right it seemed that God said
you know what should we kill that since
what should we do about this Here I am
he wasn't talking to himself so I kind
of get that their separate being correct
but very okay so what about a man nature
sure so what about worship and prayer
well clearly Jesus can be worshipped
there's no question about that the
disciples worshiped him if you go to the
book of Revelation it talks about angels
worshipping Christ angels worshiping the
Father you don't have a direct reference
of angels worshiping the Holy Spirit
which is kind of interesting it's not
the Holy Spirit is not divine but the
Holy Spirit is not manifest in the same
form as the father and the son in
Revelation the Holy Spirit is symbolized
by seven burning lamps of fire and is
represented by a dove or sometimes
referred to as the wind arm so
definitely the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit they share the
characteristics of deity and they are
worthy of worship but when it comes to
prayer specifically we only have one
example in the Bible of somebody praying
directly to Jesus and that was at the
stoning of Stephen with Stephen cried
out said Lord Jesus receive my spirit
that's the only reference that we have
of someone in the Bible praying
specifically to Christ are throughout
scripture the abundant evidence is that
when we pray we are to pray to God the
Father in the name of Jesus we don't
have any reference specifically of
somebody praying to the Holy Spirit
although there's nothing wrong in
praying to the father and asking for the
Holy Spirit
matter of fact Jesus says you need to
ask the Father and He will give you the
Holy Spirit so there's nothing
intrinsically wrong in praying to Jesus
but following the example gay
in scripture the correct manner of
prayer is to pray to the Father in the
name of Jesus for the Holy Spirit okay
I'm on one it actually does one more
question okay with regards with regards
term abortion but obviously the muscles
from what I read worshipped Christ what
would worship meaning that you know
worship is not only adoration and praise
that's part of worship but true worship
is willing obedience and to worship
Christ is to obey Him it is to receive
his teachers teachings it is to put it
in to practice it is to become dependent
upon him
you know we worship through prayer we
worship through song
but the greatest act of worship is
through obedience and Jesus says whoever
hears these sayings of mine and does
them I will liken him unto a wise man a
matter of fact Jesus said in the last
day there will be many saying Lord Lord
did we not prophesy in your name and
cast out devils and so on and Jesus's I
never knew you because they didn't do
what he told them to do so true worship
is an act of obedience which includes
adoration and praise but primarily what
God is looking for is a whirling heart
to do his will and Carl for further
study I was just going to add you can we
have some free offers the first one is
called the Trinity yes that relates to
your first question and those that are
listening you can go to just call one
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the Trinity
the second one is teach us to pray
pastor Doug did that one as well as the
Trinity and they're just excellent
resources for you to continue in your
walk with the Lord okay that number pole
for the free resource again is 1 808 3
five six seven four seven alright and if
you'd like to get a call in on the
program tonight 800 four six three seven
two nine seven who do we have next
we have Phil from Long Island New York
Phil you're on the air with Bible
answers live
I feel walking program we have just a
few minutes okay could you hear me okay
we can okay you guys are doing a great
job I thank you for taking my call I
have a question about which I think
there is disagreement even amongst you
origins and the question is this in
order that the second advent of Jesus
can take place is it necessary that
there first be a third Jewish temple
where is Jesus himself the third temple
good question all right I'm going to
give you a quick answer yeah but it's
kind of deep so you'll need to put your
thinking cap on there are five different
types of temples or sanctuaries that are
referenced in the scriptures
you have the one that's in heaven we
know that from the book of Hebrews we
also know that when Moses built the
temple or the sanctuary in the
wilderness he followed a pact that was
shown to him in the Mount so you have
the heavenly sanctuary
you got the earthly and when I talk
about the Earth Day I'm talking about
one Moses built and then Solomon finally
built and then it was replaced after the
70 years of Babylonian captivity that's
the earth day so you have the heavenly
sanctuary of the earthly sanctuary
there's three others Jesus speaking of
himself said destroy this temple in
three days I'll raise it up again he
wasn't talking about the temple in
Jerusalem but he was talking about
himself
so Jesus is described as a temple and
then the Bible tells us in the New
Testament no you're not that your body
is the temple of the Holy Spirit so you
have the individual if the Spirit is
within us we are symbolized by the
temple and then the church as a whole is
also referred to as the temple of God
and we're all living stones in that
temple and Jesus is the cornerstone so
when you talk about a temple we need to
realize that the earthly that was on the
earth finally destroyed in 70 AD was
just a shadow or a type of the true
temple the one in heaven where Jesus
ministers for us today
much focus has been put upon an earthly
temple being rebuilt but if you go to
the book of Hebrews the real focus is on
the heavenly sanctuary where Jesus
ministers is our high priest in heaven
will the temple be rebuilt in Jerusalem
uh I don't know maybe maybe not but does
it have to be rebuilt in order for Jesus
to come no that is a misunderstanding of
a prophecy that you read about in the
book of Daniel Daniel chapter 9 in
particular we people have misunderstood
or misapplied those various prophetic
time periods but the true focus today is
on
a heavenly sanctuary and the work that
Jesus is doing for us I know that that's
a lot of information but we said a
calculation but you clarified things and
you did a hell of a good job okay so
very much for your consideration
like you said you call who do we have
next we have Edward Loma Linda
California Edward you're on the air with
Bible answers live thanks very much
pastor I think you're a very excellent
great Leonard and I appreciate your
commentaries thank you very much and God
bless
well thanks for calling it but what's
your questions evening the question is
do we follow as in registration and John
and Matthew do we follow the Ten
Commandments you know whether we do we
follow the Sabbath of the Catholic
Church the way change is 3:58 by by
drink oxygen as we follow the Sabbath
that the Lord Jesus Christ shed follow
God's commandments all right well good
good question Edward you know I'm going
to be honest with you if you look at the
New Covenant in the New Testament the
New Covenant is the Ten Commandments
written upon the heart there's no
question about that that's the New
Covenant now if the Ten Commandments are
written upon the heart a true believer
in Christ will want to keep all Ten
Commandments not 9 not 8 a pen the
fourth commandment we know is remember
the Sabbath day to keep it holy so for
the Christian today yes if we are
committed to following what Jesus asks
us to do we would want to keep the
Sabbath not a man-made institution or a
man-made tradition but the Sabbath as
given in the Bible I know there's a
number of Christians who are
rediscovering this precious wonderful
truth about the Sabbath and the rest and
the blessing behind it and I would
encourage anyone to study that further
we do have a study guide called last day
in history it kind of talks a little bit
about this and I think for any of our
listeners if you're curious about that
please give us a call and we'll be happy
to send that to you what's that number
that number is
seven four seven and the title of that
pastor joining in its last day in
history and I think you'd find it and
also there's another one called written
in stone on the Ten Commandments it's
also both very good studies well we've
got time for at least one more caller
who do we have next we have Rob and
Dearborn Michigan hi Rob we got just a
few minutes what's your question yes sir
yes sir this is this question was asked
by one of my daughters her name is
Rachel okay and in Genesis chapter 31 it
speaks of Jacob's leaving the house of
Laban mm-hmm and he takes Rachel and
Leah with him and Rachel takes some
idols with her and she was asking why
did she take those idols so Jacob knew
what the real God was who he was
yeah and why did why the wait she'll do
this why did you do it well you know I
think back up a little bit more Laban
knew about the true God because it goes
all the way back to Abraham and
Abraham's family they worship the true
God but one of the reasons why God
brought Abraham away from his family and
brought him to the land of promise was
because included in their worship of the
true God they had been influenced by the
cultures around them and some idols came
into their form of worship and God
wanted to separate Abraham from that so
he could worship God in truth so when
you have Jacob going back and he marries
Rachel and Leah and they journey now to
the promised land there was still
certain significance that they attached
to these idols and it was a learning
process they need to learn to let go of
it and God was working with them and
leading them and that's why she took
them she should not have taken them we
know that worshiping idols is a
violation of the second commandment it's
not something that anyone should do I
don't know whether she was worshiping
the idols or whether she was just taking
along as a good-luck charm that could
very well have been the case to try and
connect it to a family but you know it
caused problems cause problems with
Laban and Jacob and the family and there
was never God's will and I think this is
why God was calling them back to Bethel
which means the house of God the
children were so true worship so he
realized they were struggling with some
things like we all tend to struggle but
he
always trying to call us home he's
leading us and he wants us to get rid of
certain things and cast them aside and
this is that case it was kind of a
growing experience that Rachel needed to
to go through all right well take you
pastor I appreciate your ministry all
right well thank you for your call we
appreciate it
well friends I'm looking at how much
time we've gotten it doesn't look like
we've got time to take one more caller
we probably wouldn't do it justice if we
did and if it didn't get to your call
tonight we hope you won't get
discouraged but call us back next week
and we'll try and answer as many calls
as we possibly can you know we gave a
lot of free offers out this evening and
if you missed any of them and would like
to receive one be sure to give us a call
on our resource phone number that number
is 885 six seven four seven and you can
just ask for that free offering will
they have to descend it to you but
pastor Marshall if somebody wants to
read one of these articles right away or
take a look at one of these books what
do they do they just need to go to
amazing fax org
and all of this most of this materials
right there for you online you can just
click on it download it listen to
whatever you want to there's a lot of
information and amazing not only do we
have printed material there at the web
site but there's a lot of sermons and
printable there are videos that's rate
available so please be sure to take a
look at our website it's just amazing
facts dot o-r-g and you'll just find a
storehouse of information information
but I think you'll find very helpful and
why are you there if you've been blessed
by this program and would like to keep
us on the air we would encourage you to
donate there's a little link that you
can click on to keep this program on the
air reaching the lives of hundreds and
thousands of people around the world so
thank you for your support frames we
hope that this has been a blessing and
we just want to encourage you to spend
time in God's Word take time to study
the scriptures you indeed will be
blessed until we need next week god
bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz and the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing facts
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]